hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about how to solve equations and you
might ask why are we doing math in
biology class well it turns out there
are a lot of applications for solving
equations in various aspects of biology
which we'll talk about in effect the
first look look at the basics of how to
solve an equation while you solve an
equation by solving for the unknown
variable and to do this you have to
rearrange the equation a basic example
of this is the kind of thing that you've
seen in algebra class something like 3x
plus 2 equals 14 here the unknown
variable is X and in order to solve for
x we have to rearrange the equation we
do this by isolating the variable that
is making it to where the variable is
the only thing on one side of the equal
sign so to do this we will subtract two
from each side which gives us 3x equals
12 this is because 3x plus 2 minus 2
equals 3x + 14 minus 2 equals 12 then to
continue isolating that unknown variable
will divide both sides by 3 this gives
us x equals 4 this is because 3x divided
by 3 is x + 12 divided by three is four
you can always double check your math by
plugging the answer that you got back
into the original equation that is three
times four equals twelve plus two equals
14 so we've done it correctly here are
some examples of where you might use
this in a biology class diluting
solutions for example in a lot
suit situation where you know perhaps
the molarity and the volume and you know
the new molarity you want to make its by
rearranging this equation that you can
determine the new volume so the amount
of solvent that you have to add to get
to the new molarity something like gives
free energy or solving for solute
potential these are all examples of
where you might have to rearrange an
equation if you are given some of the
pieces of the puzzle some of the
variables and asked to solve for another
one for example if you were doing a
gibbs free energy problem that is this
one right here and you were able to
measure or determine the information for
Delta G Delta H and you know the
temperature you might have to solve for
Delta X the way that you would do this
is by isolating Delta s let's look at it
right here first we would subtract Delta
H from each side this gives us Delta G
minus Delta H equals negative T Delta s
and then we can divide both sides by
negative T and this gives us that delta
x equals Delta G minus Delta H divided
by negative T so that is another example
of solving an equation in a biology
application that is it for today thanks
for watching